[Musique]
mélanie poquet désormais avec moi pour
son coup de coeur culture bonsoir alors
pour ceux qui ont la chance de profiter
de leurs vendredi un long week-end de
quatre jours les attend l'occasion de
profiter de nombreux rendez vous
culturel que propose le territoire il y
aura encore mélanie un choix à faire
toujours mais il ya surtout pour tous
les goûts les amoureux de cinéma de
musique de théâtre vont être servis car
ce week-end débute un des grands rendez
vous culturels de la ville de versailles
c'est le mois molière c'est la 24e
édition et comme chaque année un mois de
théâtre mais aussi de musique de
conférences dans la cité royale de
nombreuses créations dès le début du
festival puisque les 1er 2 juin la
grande écurie accueil accompagné de
l'éternel était elle est en résidence
elle jouera le capitaine fracasse
d'après théophile gautier le dramaturge
français est aussi à l'honneur vous
pourrez aussi des ainsi découvrir ou
découvrez le dépit amoureux les
fourberies de scapin les fachos
difficile bien sûr de tout donné donc le
plus simple c'est de se rendre sur le
site du festival qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran à rambouillet c'est un
anniversaire qui est célébrée celui d'un
fameux festival woodstock tout
simplement
il a 50 ans du 15 au 18 18 août 1969
près d'un demi million de spectateurs
sont rassemblé 32 groupes se succèdent
sur trois jours et demi avec du folk du
blues du rock et de la soul je vous
éviterez les noms ambiance est tous très
connu à pour cet anniversaire c'est
l'usiné à chapeaux qui prévoit plusieurs
jours de fête on va les voir s'afficher
à l'écran ça débute ce vendredi qu'une
conférence elle sera présentée par henri
chartier spécialiste des musiques
actuelles et de la chanson française
il reviendra sur les temps forts de
l'événement et surtout ses répercussions
mais pour cet événement les groupes des
studios de l' usine à chapeaux seront
aussi à l'honneur
et oui les équipes de monde au public de
se parer de ses plus belles chemises à
fleurs et pantalons pattes d'eph pour le
concert du 1er juin qui débute à 20h
foot + accueil pour fermin et amel bent
sera sur la scène aux mureaux eh oui la
chanteuse française revient après quatre
ans d'absence elle démarre sa tournée le
1er juin et pour le concert des mureaux
il ne faudra pas beaucoup plus patiente
et puisqu'elle chantera ce dimanche de
juin elle défendra notamment son nouvel
album demain et bien sûr
4 à ses plus grands succès mais votre
plus grand succès avoue mélanie c'est le
7-8 culture et vous l'interprétez dans
un instant juste après ce journal